Fran Homer is the perfect introductory
speaker to get this started she is
currently president obama's appointee as
the chair of the US Arctic research
commissioned so and I think she'll say a
little bit about that so I won't say too
much but what she does there has helped
lead the research and inquiry into what
is happening in the Arctic on many
issues not just climate but obviously
climate is a crucial issue in the Arctic
previously and I'm not going to get this
in exactly the right order but Fran was
on the commission that studied the BP
Deepwater Horizon spill she was the
Chancellor of the University of Alaska
Anchorage she was also a visiting
professor and director of a Center at
the University she was lieutenant
governor of the state of Alaska which I
discovered today she served under
governor Knowles who in addition to
being a Yale graduate himself his son is
an FPS graduate his son graduating with
me in 2009 and I just fair warning if
you if his name was Lucas knowles and be
careful when you google him because I
discovered some things I didn't intend
to discover not about him but some other
Lucas Knowles out there in the world so
I'll let you figure that out for
yourselves so without further ado I want
to welcome Fran Fran thank you very much
for being here and this is a great way
to kick off the series well thank you
very much Josh and to the entire team
here at Yale that invited me and have
made my stay so pleasant thank you very
much and I want to thank all of you for
coming tonight to talk about the Arctic
and talk about Alaska and some of the
challenges that we face it's such a
beautiful night outside I'm going to try
to keep my remarks relatively brief and
save time for question and answers so
that we can talk about some of the
things that you really want to talk
about in addition to what I want to talk
about and then for you off to enjoy this
beautiful evening when i go back to
Alaska tomorrow I'm expecting snow so
I'm actually looking forward to a little
walk tonight myself so let me let me
begin by saying that the Arctic in
general is really heating up in a
variety of ways including media coverage
it's as though all of a sudden a lot of
the world discovered that there's a very
interesting place called the Arctic
there is a great deal of coverage about
it in comparison to how it used to be
and this is primarily focused on climate
change but not exclusively it is focused
on a region that for a long time has
been sort of a curiosity a place where
adventurers went explorers went
scientists went to do research but not
something that most people frankly
identified with unless they happen to
have visited there or had some unique
association with it but now there's a
lot of coverage and the coverage I would
say as a longtime Alaskan is a little
superficial but what we're going to do
tonight is get a little deeper into what
is the Arctic what are some of the
changes that are being experienced in
the Arctic and what are the challenges
associated with adaptation for society
as we move through this period of really
radical change and that's what I want to
really emphasize if you don't remember
anything else about what I say tonight
what I want you to think about is the
pace of change now the environment
ecology and societies and cultures and
economies are always changing we're not
a static anything what is really
significant about the Arctic at this
point in time is the pace of change the
pace of warming and the pace of cultural
and economic change that is going along
with this ecological change warming
temperatures less sea ice thawing
permafrost vulnerable species that tends
to get covered somewhat superficially
but let's back up a step just for a
moment and remember what is the Arctic
the Arctic is an ocean surrounded by
eight countries let's contrast that to
an Africa Antarctica is land surrounded
by water Antarctica has penguins the
Arctic has people and there are many
differences in addition to that but one
of the most significant ones as we think
about this period of change is that
Antarctica is a place where the
governments of the world have decided
that it is a special place for science
and international peace the Arctic does
not have an overarching treaty anything
like that as a matter of fact it's a
place where the eight Arctic nations
that surround the Arctic Ocean have
national agendas and they have some very
specific ideas about how they want to
move forward in the Arctic as it enters
this new era this by the way is a map
that defines the Arctic as Congress
defined the Arctic when it passed in
nineteen eighty-four the law that
created the u.s. Arctic research
commissioned as i mentioned people live
in the Arctic which differentiates it
from what most people think of as the
Arctic as a cold dark place where there
aren't a lot of people but four million
people live in the Arctic across all of
those Arctic states and many of them are
indigenous people this is a photograph
of inupiat eskimo women in Barrow that
I've are waiting for the whale to be
shared at a whale feast in the spring
many of the indigenous people of the
Arctic
not all but many and those certainly in
Alaska have very strong cultural
traditions associated with the place
where they live as a matter of fact what
they admire most and love about their
space is that it is a very productive
ecosystem it is a productive ecosystem
that for centuries really was the way in
which they survive without many of the
conveniences and without grocery stores
and without electricity remarkably a
people that have been superb and
adapting to the very challenging
conditions of the Arctic for many
centuries they and other people in
Alaska that we refer to as indigenous
people but there are many different
Alaska Native peoples live off the land
and we call that subsistence where you
hunt you fish you gather you share and
as you might imagine now that we are in
the 21st century the cultures are no
longer singularly subsistence dependent
they are now mixed cash and subsistence
economies nonetheless in many places and
this is certainly true in Alaska but in
other places in the Arctic as well the
reliance on a healthy ecosystem and the
ability to continue to use not only what
is available to you but to share it and
to have your cultural and social
networks really be built on that is
important for us to remember at the same
time we're keeping track of how rapidly
the Arctic is changing all of this
depends upon a healthy ecosystem the
ecosystem of the Arctic is fundamentally
an ice dependent ecosystem in other
words all of the species there and let's
just take a Laska as an example the
Chukchi in the Beaufort as ecosystems
where this is very evident everything
revolves around ice when is the freeze
up when is the thaw and all of the
species that are very dependent upon ice
and that's everything from very very
small things to very very large things
like polar bears are impacted as the ice
changes and again that's something to
keep in mind as we think about the rapid
rate of change so how rapid is this
change so this is just a picture i'm
sure most of you have seen the contrast
between the summer sea ice extent in
2002 vs2012 went one of the years one of
the several years in this decade where
we have reached all-time lows in the
amount of sea ice in the summer let's
remember it's still always there in the
winter but it's in the summer that we're
talking about a radical change in the
amount of summer sea ice how radical the
change fifty percent less in extent and
seventy-five percent less in volume and
let that sink in for a moment that is a
huge change in a pretty short period of
time and the volume change reflects what
is also happening in terms of multi-year
ice in other words ice that used to be
there and would stay there all summer
long and that would get built on again
as it would freeze up in the fall but
would always be there now we're seeing
the disappearance of multi-year sea ice
which again has tremendous implications
for the ecosystem for the species of all
sizes that rely upon ice as the
organizing principle of their survival
so how much has Alaska warm just as one
of the arctic areas that we will focus
on tonight rather dramatically four
degrees in the summer and about 7
degrees in the winter that contrasts
just by way of reference to about one
degree of warming globally so as you can
see the Arctic is warming much more
dramatically than any other place on
earth what does that mean to Arctic
residents well we could spend a whole
hour talking about that alone but to
kind of summarize it in three big ways
the impact on subsistence food that I
mentioned earlier and the way in which
the cultures of the North rely upon
whales and walrus and seals and many
other species the impacts to the coastal
villages in the extent to which their
infrastructure
may be crumbling because of thawing
permafrost and on the upside potentially
some economic development opportunities
that didn't previously exist but that
might exist now just because of the
greater degree of accessibility for some
regions as the ice retreats and as
people think about economic development
opportunities that weren't as readily
available when it was colder or more ice
present so let's just draw a couple of
pictures in your mind and a picture here
to sort of show you what I mean when I
describe communities being impacted in a
rather dramatic way permafrost is
permanently frozen ground that has a
thin layer of topsoil on top and how
deep that top soil is varies from place
to place in Alaska or in other places
where there's permafrost like Russia so
here you see a picture of permafrost
that's that ice stuff and a little bit
of layer on the top and a huge chunk
that has come apart from the land so as
permafrost thaws and there is a lot of
thawing going on in the north and as
coastal erosion is increasing as a
result of several factors which I will
describe more and more of the villages
in Alaska as well as villages in other
places but this is particularly
pronounced and visible to me as a person
who lives at Alaska are losing their
coastline and that means potentially and
in some cases actually losing their
roads losing a school losing houses as
they fall into the sea so why is the
coastal erosion happening also because
of warming conditions so I want you to
imagine the Beaufort or the Chukchi or
the Bering Sea covered with ice and a
hurricane-force wind coming up at 20
degrees below zero and what happens as
that wind blows across the ice versus
what happens if that wind is blowing
across open water it's blowing across
open water you get huge waves if it's
blowing across ice ice acts like a
blanket on the
water and keeps down the amount of wave
action and coastal erosion so what has
happened with retreating ice and less of
that blanket is the wind and the waves
could have a much bigger impact on
coastlines and that's what's happening
it's eroding coastlines in some seasons
in some storms by 50 feet by 70 feet so
the combination of the warming the
thawing of the permafrost and this
coastal erosion force of waves on the
coastline is what's doing tremendous
damage to villages and to the coastline
of Alaska so what's happening
communities are talking about moving so
community is like Shishmaref and new
talk and Kivalina and others are
actually they Sushma RF is a great
example they've voted to move to
relocate to a different place because
they have to they're basically losing
their communities the US Army Corps of
Engineers has identified more than 30
villages that in our lifetimes will have
to move in Alaska alone so this is a big
deal how in the world do you cope with
this you can't build walls that will
protect these villages moving them is
prohibitively expensive who will pay for
it when we're talking about villages of
a few hundred people maybe as much as a
thousand people will the federal
government pay for and an era of
sequestration probably not so how is
this going to happen a big unanswered
question but it is a piece of what we
must focus on as we think about how do
we adapt life given the changing
conditions in the Arctic region it also
means that we have to do a different
kind of engineering designing and
constructing of our infrastructure roads
airports ports building schools have to
be built now with the knowledge that
that thawing permafrost including in
areas interior to Alaska like Fairbanks
they have to be constructed differently
and although this isn't being
necessarily required it is being
discussed by the engineering community
in Alaska how do you plan for 20 30 40
year building life knowing the rapid
rate of change that is taking place even
now as we are experiencing it so it's
very challenging to the engineering the
design community to the construction
community to the public sector and the
private sector to adapt the entire way
of thinking about how you construct
buildings and roads to a very different
reality and one by the way that is
continuing to change creating some very
interesting problems I might note that
what is happening in the Arctic is not
just impacting the Arctic and this is
something particularly for those of you
who don't live in the Arctic I want to
emphasize that what happens in the
Arctic doesn't stay in the Arctic the
Arctic is for all practical purposes a
refrigerator for the planet it makes a
huge difference in terms of the weather
that you experience in North America it
will as time goes by play out in a wide
variety of ways that will impact your
communities and your life again this is
a whole nother hour long lecture about
weather and I'm not a climate scientist
I'm not an atmospheric scientist I mean
oceanographer but the sum total and i'll
give you just sort of those the elevator
speech on this is that there's a
tremendous and important interaction
between how much precipitation is in the
atmosphere what the temperature of the
ocean is the extent to which polar highs
and polar lows change the jet stream if
the jet stream is moving across North
America more slowly it means instead of
a rain storm that lasts for six hours it
may last for three days which will have
implications with regard for example
flooding or how long a snow storm lasts
in Boston as to how long the boston
airport is closed down the pace at which
weather changes is being impacted
dramatically by warming in the Arctic
again there's a fair amount of work
that's being done in this field right
now and
expect and I just tuned you up two
remaining curious about these
interactions between what is happening
in the Arctic and what is happening in
your own backyard so let's talk a little
bit about what's driving all of this my
my speech this evening is really not
about climate change policy but as I've
mentioned many times it is about the
warming of the Arctic and I think in the
context of where we are right now in
this country but in other countries as
well connecting the dots so to speak for
people about what is changing in the
Arctic what is changing in your backyard
and what decisions need to be made not
only in the state houses in Congress in
federal agencies but in our own lives
and the choices that we make is a very
important piece of this equation even
though we're talking about adaptation we
have to take keep that in the context of
the long-term changes that the globe is
experiencing so what are some of the
decision points about the adaptation
that needs to take place in the Arctic
and what humans can choose to do about
it and I would just note interestingly
enough all of the eight Arctic nations
have national strategies that articulate
some big picture goals for what they
want and hope for the Arctic and how
they want and hope to get there the
United States was one of the last ones
to actually do this in april of this
year the White House came out with a
national Arctic strategy for the United
States and you can google it it lays out
in sort of three big pillars security
stewardship and international
cooperation of some of the hopes and
dreams and plans for the artic these
three pillars are very similar to the
National Arctic strategies that you
would find if you went to Google the
Canadian Arctic strategy or the Russian
Arctic strategy or the Norwegian artic
strategy very similar themes what is
different as you look about all of these
is
extent to which they get to the next
level of detail about what action will
actually be taken for the adaptation for
the planning for the investment that
will be necessary to move forward in the
Arctic in a safe way the one and pretty
much only body that brings all eight of
those Arctic nations together to do
cooperative collaborative work is
something called the Arctic Council the
Arctic Council has existed since the
mid-1990s as a place not wear a lot of
decisions get made no but as a place
where people can share information it
has had a heavy emphasis on things like
sustainable development and on climate
change and on ecosystem based management
and on ways in which communities States
nations scientists public sector and
private sector can work together in a
responsible way to develop a region that
is very both valuable and vulnerable and
I just mention this because it's very
timely that the United States is sort of
upping its game in the Arctic because
we're about to become the chair of the
Arctic Council Canada is the chair now
and in a year and a half the United
States will become the chair what will
the United States choose to do with that
chairmanship for it so Narvik for the
Arctic as a whole what leadership world
will we play on questions like
adaptation and responsible development
this is a question to which I don't have
an answer and I'm hoping that the
administration will when our
chairmanship rolls around soon but it's
an important thing and I think it's an
important thing for we as Americans
regardless of whether we live in the
Arctic or live here to think about what
is our responsibility as a leader as an
Arctic nation to take the Arctic Council
to the next level so how do we do this
adapting to what we can see is coming
not just the climate change in the
warming but the human the increased
human activities is a
salt of that and I guess we can bunch
them into sort of these general
categories of shipping fisheries tourism
mining and oil and gas that is certainly
what the media is covering as it covers
what is happening and what may happen in
the Arctic as a result of increased
access so how can these things be
planned for regulated managed and
undertaken in a responsible way in a
region that as I said is both vulnerable
and valuable so let's explore this just
a little bit but before we explore those
let's just remember what we're talking
about here we're talking about a region
that is very challenging it's very cold
it's dark for long periods of time it
has extreme weather it's a place where
it is very expensive to do business it
is a place where you really need
specialized technology if you're going
to do it whatever it is responsibly it
is a place with very little
infrastructure existing that could help
you do whatever it is you plan to do or
help you get out of trouble if you get
into trouble in the Arctic and it is a
place where again there are indigenous
people in subsistence cultures that have
certain expectations about the social
contract between people coming from the
outside to kind of do business there and
people who live there and have hopes and
dreams of their own that they don't
necessarily want somebody from the
outside telling them what to do so those
are some of the challenges now in that
context let's talk about some of these
things that need to be adapted planned
for and undertaken in a responsible way
oil and gas it's a big deal why is it a
big deal in the Arctic because the US
Geological Survey has estimated that up
to thirty percent of the remaining
natural gas in the world and fifteen
percent of the remaining oil in the
world is in the Arctic and they get that
old saying about follow the money will
follow the oil where there is oil you
can bet
that there will be an interest in
exploration and development and there
certainly is even now even as we speak
there has been development for quite a
while particularly in some places like
on the shore in Alaska or in Norway but
there is a lot of hope that there will
be a lot more by many people who are
very very interested in the development
just to give you sort of a timeline of
how this has happened in one place in
alaska i'm going to show you the
difference on this map between what kind
of oil development we had in 1968 in
1977 in 1989 and in 2001 so you can see
sort of what happens when you begin to
explore and develop the infrastructure
grows and you have to be very thoughtful
about how you're doing that to make
certain that what you are doing is not
negatively impacting the environment
there is a lot more development that is
on the cusp in the US Arctic the
Department of Interior has leased both
in the chukchi and the Beaufort and
shale and ConocoPhillips and Statoil
have been pursuing the possibility of
additional exploration there that has
raised concerns about how it can be done
safely particularly given that it is
offshore versus on shore now for a long
time there of course has been a
controversy associated with additional
unsure development in the Alaskan Arctic
and that's usually teed up in the
context of the Alaska National Wildlife
Refuge the Arctic National Wildlife
Refuge the National Petroleum area but
for many Alaskans the concern is even
greater associated with the development
in the chukchi and the Beaufort simply
because it represents a very different
kind of technology that will have to be
deployed what are most people most
concerned about of course the most
concerned about is if there's an oil
spill are we ready for it this is one of
the documents that the US Arctic
research Commission which I chair has
recently produced which looks at this
question what science has been done to
explore how you
clean up a spill in the Arctic and this
report which is available online at
Arctic gov and I do actually have one
copy and we'll go to the highest bidder
it basically looks at what has been done
by either the public sector or the
private sector by oil industry by
government by anywhere I mean Norway
Finland anywhere and what are the
remaining questions that haven't been
answered and so that is the concern that
is the challenge and that is very much
on the minds of people whether they live
in the Arctic or other places so that's
sort of sort of the oil and gas
development arena and before I leave
this I just want to say the pew pew just
came out this week with a call to action
for Arctic wide oil and gas standards to
kind of up the game on whether that
development takes place in Russia or
Canada or Greenland or Iceland or Alaska
and for those of you are particularly
interested in this topic and curious
about this question of should we be
developing it in the Arctic at a very
different level should we be adapting
our regulatory regimes recognizing how
challenging this region is so I would
just urge you to take a look at the Pew
report that just came out two days ago
that raises this question about Arctic
standards so what about shipping that's
a lot of what gets covered in the inland
media right this very intriguing idea
that instead of things being shipped
through the Suez Canal or the Panama
Canal that things might be shipped over
the top so again let's start with the
basics the Green Line is the Northwest
Passage the orange or yellowish line is
the northern sea route these are two
very different places the northern sea
route goes above Russia and for many
reasons that we don't have time to go
into that is far more likely to be the
shipping route than the Northwest
Passage because of ice because of
transport because of availability of
icebreakers Russia has 37 of them we
have 11 and a half it's just for a lot
of reasons the more likely route and
already the shipping has increased I
won't say dramatically but
substantially in the northern sea route
so some people are saying oh this is
going to be a major shipping route I
would just say maybe not quite so fast
because there are some significant
things to remember about it again
remember it's only during the summer
that were ice-free it's still icy fall
winter and spring so can you really
change the shipping economics the
logistics associated with the shipping
industry for a few months it's an
interesting question not to mention
there's very limited charting limited
mapping limited infrastructure so yes it
will increase there's no doubt in my
mind but that's true the extent to which
that happens and what kind of ships it
will be all of those things I think the
jury is still out but but yes there will
be more shipping what is challenging is
the adaptation of the business practices
of the shipping industry whether it's
shipping oil and gas or shipping
anything else to this area back to our
theme of adaptation adaptation for an
industry means thinking about what it is
not only that's unique about that place
but how it's changing and as we've
talked about many times tonight the pace
of change is dramatic so things that
need to be done increasing the mapping
and the charting building more
infrastructure more ports more refuge
areas adopting the IMO mandatory polar
code so that ships have to meet a
certain standard if they are going to
ship in the Arctic training the people
who will be working on these ships so
that they're actually able to deal with
the ice conditions because you can get
ice at any time of year there are a lot
of things associated with the adaptation
if this industry is going to move
forward and not to mention the law the
sea treaty that the United States needs
to adopt has yet to ratify in the US
Senate unlike over a hundred and forty
other nations that are moving forward I
might add under the law the sea treaty
to prove up their extended continental
shelf claims which the United States
will not be able to until we ratify this
treaty that's another hour lecture that
I will spare
you tonight so let's talk a little bit
about fisheries it's another thing that
sometimes gets covered in some areas in
the Arctic there are ready fisheries of
course north of Iceland Norway etc but
in the US Arctic the federal government
has imposed a moratorium a moratorium
that basically recognizes we don't know
enough about fish populations in the
chukchi and the Beaufort to sustainably
manage a fishery there and that's a wise
move so at least in our neck of the
woods that moratorium is sort of
treading water shall we speak we're
holding until we do more science and
there are certainly people who at the
State Department and in other places are
trying to get that kind of a moratorium
considered by other nations in the
Arctic as well particularly given that
there are a lot of things happening in
the Arctic that we don't even understand
fully for example ocean acidification as
more and more co2 is absorbed by the
oceans and as we know cold water holds
on to co2 more than warm water I just
think of a coke that's warm versus a
coke that's cold obviously acidification
in Arctic waters is a significant
concern in terms of what that does to a
wide variety of species so again it's
best to be cautious use the
precautionary principle when we're
talking about fisheries in the Arctic
shipping as it also includes tourism
this number actually stunned me when the
US Coast Guard gave me this estimate of
200,000 cruise ship passengers in the
Arctic this summer given the lack of
infrastructure and the lack of ability
to respond in case of an emergency like
Oh for example you know the coastal the
Korea I mean it just is crazy to me but
at any rate that's what's happening and
all of these things I think cry out for
us as responsible people to adapt not
only what we're thinking about might be
possible but to be doing the planning
and the very area and region-specific
regulation adaptation of regulation to
accommodate the very challenging
conditions of the Arctic so as we adapt
to the future what do we need to do as a
society a lot of things differently than
what we are doing today and one of the
most important things I think is simply
admitting my very first point which is
how rapid the rate of change is
happening in the Arctic and how rapid
that rate of change is likely to impact
places beyond the Arctic so planning for
it is absolutely essential how do you
make good decisions about any host of
these things I think you have to do the
science you have to do the research to
be able to answer the fundamental
questions about how our ecosystem is
changing and what kind of technology and
engineering designs will really work
given these changing conditions and then
given the punishing conditions of the
Arctic research unquestionably is a
piece of the answer and as research
budgets shrink and particularly at this
time of sequestration and concern about
budgets it is happening at just the
wrong moment if you ask me when we
really have to be making decisions about
how we move forward not only in the
Arctic but in other places where
adaptation is essential so let me just
close with a brief word about the u.s.
Arctic research commissioned before I
open this up to questions the Commission
as I mentioned was created by Congress
in 1984 largely with an eye toward
giving advice giving advice to the
president to federal agencies and
Congress about research priorities in
the Arctic and we do that in a variety
of ways we do that by publishing things
like the goals report which is at the
back table which kind of describes for
you some of the key areas that we think
are incredibly important for additional
investment in Arctic research we do it
by doing special papers like the one
that I mentioned on oil spills in ice we
do it by convening
I work for having basically task forces
by having working groups by convening
different federal agencies that need to
do a better job of talking to each other
and sharing their resources as they do
their Arctic science plans there are a
lot of ways in which we tend to be
facilitators to try to get people to get
the most bang for the buck possible with
the Arctic research dollars that we have
but we also want to make sure that
people are aware of the research that
has been done so that they don't simply
duplicate it or so that they don't say
gee I don't know the answer to that
question so I'm just going to wing it
whether they're in the public sector or
the private sector making decisions so
we do something called the Arctic update
it's a daily electronic newsletter all
things Arctic so for those of you who
care about the Arctic and I guess to a
certain extent I'm going to assume that
you're here tonight so you care about
the Arctic go to Arctic gov and you can
sign up for the electronic newsletter
which will every single day give you
just a little snapshot of what's going
on around the Arctic what's happening in
Greenland what's happening in Finland
what's happening in Russia not just
Arctic research but also public policy
pronouncements major investments new
initiatives by private sector it's
something that could be a useful tool to
you and the other thing that you will
find at Arctic gov is a portal that is a
portal of portals to other places where
you can find information about current
Arctic research again part of our
mission is making certain that whatever
research is being done is readily
available to the people for whom it
could be relevant as they try to make
better decisions about the Arctic about
their lives about their businesses about
how they're going to invest additional
Arctic research dollars so both of these
things the Arctic science portal and the
daily update are available at Arctic gov
so in closing let me just end where I
began by saying that the Arctic is a
very special place with some very unique
ecosystems some very challenging
conditions some amazing opportunities
and a place where the rate of change the
pace of change is happening so quickly
that it is hard for humans to really
comprehend but if we want to be
responsible stewards of a place that is
as special as the Arctic it's incumbent
upon all of us those of us who live in
the Arctic but those of us who call the
United States home and let's remember
the United States is an Arctic nation
it's incumbent upon us to use our best
available science and our most creative
thinking to be able to adapt to what
lies ahead thank you very much